this is the other thing that's
impressive like
literally everyone for the pacers who's
played has played well as bridges
gets lost in translation there nice fine
by ball for the finish
warren was just a revelation for this
franchise
in the bubble last summer in orlando
another look at that lamellar ball pass
it was really impressive in great hands
it was really in great hands
rivers quick first step get out pj takes
it from him
hornets down four
[Applause]
lamelo set him up had to pedal the metal
all quarters hit the line
this creativity short chest pass from
lamelo gets
devonte in rhythm draggage left some
meat on the bone
here we go hornets have a chance get in
there yes
lamelo found rosier 80 feet away
and that is a good connection right
there
look at that pass easy finish lamelo
ball
have a half how about that for awareness
too
terry knew exactly how much time he had
and he gets it to fall
that's a sharp stick
lamella wow a dipsy do
in the finish with the left hand changed
it from right to
left this cross over right there by
lamella leaves dragic
and his tracks oh man man
yeah yeah right we saw it left to right
[Music]
doomboya can't make the catch in traffic
lamella what a pass finds redkens
welcome back lavell this pass battle of
mello
underhanded i mean that's got to be
timing touch
miles says i missed that get it back
here comes lamela ball with his hair on
fire
a windmill he and he had to windmill it
to get it to
go down the defender was there i don't
think he could have dumped it just right
out
all right let's do look at this behind
the back pass and yet
i mean if he tries to dump that maybe
the sixers get a
hand on it windmilling oh
[Music]
he's fallen out of bounds and threw a
beautiful pass to devonta
oh my goodness didn't see that coming
deep yeah tap the top of your head
you just made a highlight and i think
saponis
it left side of your screen takes off
right around mcconnell
and flushes it down all over sabonis
boom that's a first as an nba player for
lamellar ball
this is his first shot full length
baseball pass
and garden cool off a little bit
in his pass hello right on the
money i mean he threw it right in stride
where gordon hayward just caught
it in rhythm there's almost like a
little post up just turn right over the
left shoulder
splash it pulling on to pulling for
these teammates here in the closing
minutes
james
what a pass by ball leading monk
beautifully down the open floor
lamello ball with the one-handed bounce
pass
on the money to monk charlotte's up by
four
the first two games against tirana
he's knocked down four tonight cole
anthony has it taken away
ball on the lob and reaching way back
is miles bridges
malachi able to get it back thomas
deflected charlotte way more active up
top
mcdaniels with a throw down to get up
and down the floor and
they have some personnel that can play
that way if you can get the rebound get
out and run
ball's going to find the open man
devonte graham he's tremendous in
transition gordon hayward sees
[Applause]
nothing's happening okay i'm going to
drive draw kick biz you finish it play
above the
terence davis on the floor another
rebound ball
number nine all behind of that pad
[Applause]
look at this wow that's a little flare
look at
that pass right on the money in stride
to play two-point charlotte lead
rozier back to ball a deep three
and ball matthews on ball
seven minutes to play ball gets tripped
by matthews they're going to count
that's as a continuation
he is just a janky basketball player
and that's just no middle drive but he
got garrison
matthews on that right jab step top by
two out of the timeout ball
underneath bridges able to dunk it and
again a lazy whistle
second time tonight
[Applause]
i mean that is so late
shot clock to five ball
beautiful crossover with the left nice
finish by lamela ball
yeah he has a spectacular layup package
and then ball with a quick left to right
crossover
[Applause]
the shovel pass and zeller lets gafford
go flying by
hachimura against ball good job staying
with him
[Applause]
shot clock to three rozier to ball puts
it up with
one nothing but net
[Applause]
balls jumper off the back of the rim
gets his own miss
washington thought about the three and
we're gonna have a reach and foul on
westbrook
and an and one opportunity for lamela
ball you can see the sense of urgency
lamellar ball is in attack mode
russell westbrook has been rebounding
the ball pushing the pace
westbrook with a rebound pushing he
finds hachimura underneath
gets it blocked there by bridges
back the other way washington bertons
didn't see him
and there's a dunk for pj washington
[Applause]
lamelo ball back on the floor for the
hornets
nice creative use of the backboard we're
very creative off the dribble
ball finds zeller in the paint and he
puts it in
over nerlens noel that's about all you
can do
from behind the arc too without fouling
this got that rebound surrounded by four
clippers
and it catches in with a three ball by
lamello
field goal percentages drop from the
first half to the second half and
actually
the clips have increased you see ball
nice little fade away jump shot
a combined 100 points in the ball game
the hornets with 51 of them
loose picked up by mcdaniels numbers for
the hornets three on one
lamello mcdaniels
[Applause]
lamelo zips a pass to pj good
work on the left side you get the
defense tilted over
lamellaes hit a pair in a row
leaves it for biambo soft touch by biz
lamello two in a row
that's what i'm talking about
lamello pj hooks it over jokic
lamelo streaking down the floor working
against harrison
up and under and the lamp falls good
transition d
that's where you have to stay connected
you you just can't allow those
those passes no shots to get through uh
it can handle that
bismarck biambo with two hands
bald monk rozier washington zeller
playing together
at the rim limit off pound pj
that's first place second play from that
time lamelo gets the switch
james well nobody's there anymore on his
way down
well an adjustment by lamela because he
couldn't believe nobody stopped it
to protect the ball lamello
oh yeah and a foul chance for a
three-point play
[Applause]
all right johnson misses two free throws
hornets lead by 10.
pj oh my goodness a lightning strike
pj washington middle screen roll has
worked
all night long and it's led to plays
like that
kyra lewis into the game for the first
time rookie for
new orleans lamela ball taking matters
into his own hands
the turnaround in the eight consecutive
shots before that one finally
fell mellow reads the pass steps right
in front of that left hand
bullet pass dj a couple of good
defensive plays
oh my god what are they thinking lavalo
again get in there now finally
pj washington breaks the seat
not in any kind of hurry two minutes to
play
another swooping lap for lavello
this rookie is must must
watch tv mcdaniels
oh yeah good thing about this play
people might think you're gonna run that
after timeout play for rozier so the
court is tilted there is mcdaniels in
his favorite spot
pj over to lamelo desire
he just wanted it little mellow right
here
stop hang roy williams has been here
back-to-back nights to watch kobe white
and now cole anthony and both guys
having ball games rory williams will be
america's guest for the rest of his life
another assist level ball this time he
finds pj
another offensive rebound biz saves it
to pj
you earned it biz fiambo a chin up
yeah good job by pj melo right here
just teasing bomba
late second lamelo ball
high arcing shot is good ball looking
for an and one
here comes lamelo hornets with numbers
cody zeller
and that's how we got where we're at
right now the mellow
creativity look away flips it to cody
throws it down
oh baby that's like one of the old uh
playing at the old park moves
with the chain net oh
man a nice three there
for malik monk i'd like to think he's
rooting for the owners
of the team a little bit but roy
rory's gonna be a scratch golfer here
before long good catch by biz bobbled it
got it back flips it in with the left
hand
right
[Applause]
carmelo ball gets it back from rozier
no looks at the biambo got him a dunk
[Applause]
on charlotte
here's that assist the no looker lamella
played the first seven minutes didn't
score only attempted one shot
did have a couple of assists here comes
lavello
oh the lane just opened up like the red
sea seems like the hornets were ready
for that zone